Thank you.
Okay, good morning everybody.
We're ready to go ahead with this first of eight community conferences to be held in this room today or elsewhere as well.
And so we got to stick to this schedule that we have in front of us here.
This first bill is HB 1195.
This is apportionment methods for school administrative unit costs.
And so I'd like to open it up to discussion from the seven members that are here.
We are being streamed, so when we speak, we've got to make sure our red lights are on.
So anybody up for discussion here?
We have two perspectives here.
There is the side-by-side, 1195.
You can see the left-hand side being the House version and the right-hand side being the Senate version.
The differences are referencing different areas of statute.
RSA 194C2 is the House version and 194C9 and C9A are the references in the Senate version.
One reference is more organization and structure.
The other side, alternative and budgetary type references.
Yes, Representative Cordelli.
Thank you.
The issue I see with the Senate version, which refers to C-9 and C-9A, is that the vote is based on the cumulative votes within the entire SAU so that a larger district within the SAU can outvote all the rest of the districts within that SAU, which is the age-old problem that we've wrestled with for a number of terms in terms of SAUs and co-ops.
So I think that that is the problem there, and I'm trying to double-check in the House version how the voting works, because that refers to a different section, just C2, 194C2.
But there was the possibility of adding to the Senate version a sentence that the proposed method of apportionment would be adopted only if there's a majority affirmative vote in each school district, which I think eliminates the majority, the larger district majority vote as an issue.
Further comments?
Sure.
So thank you very much, Mr.
Chair.
And sort of a question to the Chair and to the committee.
Are there really sort of two actions that would have to be taken, one of them being the apportionment of the SAU costs and how that apportionment would go into the budget and affect the individual members of the SAU?
then part two, approval by the by the SAU member districts of of their of their budgets.
So are there two steps to this, or am I missing that?
From my perspective, we're referencing that singular statute, which is the methodology of apportionment for the structure of the school cooperative or district, SAU.
I see that we're looking at two different things here in this, and I think the basic intent, as I believe the bill came, I was not prime sponsor or sponsor this thing, but it was we've had this age old issue of the small districts not having any control when it comes to apportionment and how they're working.
And we were trying to support the smaller district and ensure that their vote mattered.
Representative Damon.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Good morning, everyone.
So, I concur with what the Chair just said, that the intent of the bill was to respect the smaller districts but i think this doesn't accomplish that it um in the senate version at least it would seem very very likely that the majority vote would be with the largest district and they would always prevail over the smaller population town so it doesn't solve what was being addressed to be solved or attempted to be solved.
Mr.
Chair, can I?
Yes.
So again, I'm trying to read through C2 here and see where the voting process actually occurs.
And it looks like it's under Section H.
And in Section H, it says, and the reason I think we reference Section 2 for this is that under Section 8, if three-fifths of the votes cast on the question in each district shall vote in the affirmative.
Right?
So again, that is a definitive by district versus an entire board, you know, the whole multiple districts combined voting in the affirmative.
So I think that was the intent of why we ended up changing that was because under Section H, you have to have 60 percent vote of each district.
If any one district says no, then the question fails.
Representative Cordelli?
Yes, I think that's correct, Senator.
And in my mind, the three-fifths is a problem in that regard.
And this section was really related to organization of the SAU rather than apportionment, I believe.
Because section Roman 2, under H is under Roman two it talks about it uh establishing a planning committee and so forth um and specifically for organization of the SAU I think that's what I mentioned organization as well.
Yeah.
Further discussion.
Yes.
I'm just looking at the title of the bill here.
You need to approve a different method of the portioning.
So it seems to me if we're talking about whether the whole district should vote as one or whether you should have individual parts of the district to vote individually and then collect the votes.
So I think that it's already included that there is you can do it either way.
Go get my statute book.
Yeah.
If anyone has the statute book yeah um yeah on if anyone has the statute book i'm not it's um on page 635 it's uh c9a roman 3 if you're looking online um but it says if a majority of the voters voting in the school districts within the school administrative unit approve the question, then the provisions shall govern the adopting of the SAU budget.
So I think right there it's saying that it's the cumulative voters of all the districts.
Glenn, can you give me that statute number again?
Yeah, it's C9A, Roman 3, and it's halfway down in Roman 3.
It starts with if a majority of the voters voting in school districts.
Right.
So this goes.
Let me reread that.
So, Glenn, is it your contention that under Roman 3, this is a cumulative of the whole, all the districts combined and a majority vote of that?
Yeah.
But again, so I think versus having it be within each district.
Right.
It's cumulative.
So I think if we add a sentence onto the Senate version to the effect that pursuant to C9 and C9A, accept that the proposed method of apportionment shall be adopted only if there is a majority affirmative vote in each school district within the SAU.
You have written copies of that sentence?
Yeah, one.
Jen, could you please make a copy of the sheet that he has?
We need to have six additional copies.
Make it ten, please.
Mr.
Chair.
Yes, while we're doing that, could you summarize how it's currently being, how current law applies?
No.
No?
Okay.
Can you?
No, I mean, or I can't.
So perhaps Representative Cordelli could summarize how current law applies in this case.
I think if we're looking at apportionment, I think C9A talks about the alternative procedure and methods of adoption.
And so I think that under Roman III, current law would have the majority of voters within the entire SAU determining any re-apportionment method.
As opposed to by the member districts?
Correct.
Perhaps representing fellows.
Well, I want to really keep it to the right here right now.
So again so again if i may so again if as i read the apportionment method under nine right for the budget on on your education hymnal it's page 634 about halfway down it says the school administrative unit board shall apportion the total amount of budget among the constituent school districts in the following manner the apportionment shall be based on one half average daily membership in attendance for the previous year and one half of the most recently available equalized valuation so again that's the if they want to adopt anything different than that this is what we're talking about how they go about doing something different than this apportionment.
I think that's correct, Senator.
Well, that's statute right now, yeah.
So we have the paperwork in front of us that has represented Cordellis suggested language.
Um.
Except that the proposed method of apportionment shall be adopted only if there is a majority affirmative vote in each school district within the school administrative unit.
Mr.
Chair, yes, we ask for just a 2 minute recess.
Sure, Senate.
You meet real quick.
Yeah.
All right, you can use the office and we're going to do the same thing.
Here we got it.
Thank you.
We're back in session now.
We have a couple minutes left on this one, so I'd like to have Senator Ward, would you please speak to what your caucus came up with?
My caucus has come up with the...
We will go with the senate version with the house amendment a slight change in the uh we'd like to have an or between the rsa 194 c9 and the rsa 94 c9 dash a other than that we'll find where that.
And I'll ask you the question.
The amending language, is that the amending language which is outlined here in front of us?
Yes.
OK.
Your exception here.
Yes, that's OK.
So yeah, again, so we'll accept the amendment you proposed with the additional sentence and we want to make just one minor change and just change that and to an or between the two rsas because they are two different methods we don't want to make sure people don't think it's a combined it's one or the other is there any comment from the outside on that?
Oh, thank you.
Okay, is there any further comment?
Is there perhaps it's time then to take a a vote as a caucus and see where hr sounds like we know where you are but okay um is there a need for to further any further discussion on this from our side uh i am okay with what the Senate is suggesting.
I am too.
Representative Leno and Representative Damon.
So, just in the scenarios we talked about, will this prevent, I guess I just want to make sure I understand the consequences of what this does.
and particularly looking at the corner cases on this, not when everybody's in agreement, but when everybody's in agreement, but when there's disagreement in the apportionment.
So like we discussed, The SAU cost apportionment is created by the by the sau board and then it's brought to the to the member districts for an up down vote correct that's how i see it yes i agree okay so um so now each under under this um each member district would have to approve the um the sau budget or else the sau budget fit so you could have a small district, let's say.
Can I answer that?
Yes, Rick.
So again, the way I read this and from my practical experience on the school board is this is talking about the apportionment method, not the budget itself.
The apportionment method.
So I know in my school district, I happen to be in a cooperative school district, and we have to do apportionment every five years by our contract between the towns.
And so again, the idea behind this is that in SAU, we have multiple districts, the apportionment method.
So instead of using 50% attendance and 50% equalized valuation, if you're going to differentiate from that, change from that, any apportionment change has to be approved by all three towns that are in all three districts that are in the SAU.
That's exactly how I see it.
And so the intention is not to make it so a big SAU could change it in their benefit and have the small SAU pay a disproportionate share because they changed the apportionment.
This makes sure that everybody's in agreement, that everybody agrees by a 51 percent vote that this is a good apportionment method.
So it's not approving the apportioned SAU budget, but the method of apportioning the SAU budget for each of the members.
That's approved in the agreement between everybody.
And, you know, if they want to change it from a 50-50 to a 40-60, that may impact one town significantly.
And we've seen that in the North Country with one of our districts way up.
And so above us.
Yeah.
So it's about, again, it's not about the budget.
It's about the apportionment of the budget to the districts, the formula.
So what would be the unintended consequences of having any one district veto an apportionment method?
You would end up back on the default apportionment method that they had prior until a new method is approved.
And would that be the 50-50?
Is that the default?
Well, it depends on whether they're under C9 or C9A, right?
So C9 is 50% of attendance, 50%, but C9A, which is what our district is under, is we have a different methodology and it has to be approved.
So it depends on which one you're on, but yeah.
Do we need a caucus, or are we good?
We've run out of time.
Yeah, I'm good.
Okay.
Is the Senate good?
So let's take a vote from our side, Representative Damon.
Yes.
Cordelli, Vlad.
Yes?
Yes.
Thank you.
So we'll get this language written up and out to everybody and I don't think just need to have to come back.
We've got it.
Great.
Thank you very much.
Mr.
Chair, we'll have legislative services we'll send out final language to the conferees prior to sign off.
Oh, definitely.
And I've also got to contact our people over in the clerk's office.
Okay, terrific.
Thank you.
All righty.
So we've got a new cast of conferees.
So right now we're on 1695.
That's at least I don't think all our cast is here.
1695.
Bye.
No, no, you'll be.
1695.
No, no, you'll be sitting.
So we welcome to the committee represent Noble and represent Cascadden.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Here we go.
And this bill is an act relative to the release of student personally identifiable information and the, I guess, the confusion that we have in the House is, can we please have explained to us within 14 school days before the release, you know, days of the release date, and the other is informed 14 school days before the release.
That's the hang up, and I don't think this should take a heck of a lot of time, but we're confused, Senator, And that's not usual.
I think having something within a certain length of time can always give you the option of going from one day within to five days within to nine days within.
If you specify 14 days before, that's much more definitive.
And that's what we're looking for.
Your up, Senator Cordelli.
Thank you.
I agree that that's more definitive, but really this is just an informational release to parents.
There's no set action within the statute that the parent could take in relation to blocking release of the information because it's covered under FERPA.
So this is informational.
If the parent wants to go and complain to the district, I guess they can and ask for an explanation as to why the information is being released.
So I don't see a great deal of difference between within or before.
Good morning, represent Mike.
So again, I think the intention was on the Senate side is to give parents notice before the data's out, if they feel like taking action, it gives them the ability to do that, what action they can take.
Maybe just to, you know, I don't think you should be releasing my kid's data and complain, and that may be the only thing they do.
But doing it after the data is already released is kind of, you know, it doesn't give the school a chance to respond to the complaint if they want to.
And so the idea was to let a parent go in and complain, and then if they want to, because they know it's being released before the date, you know, again, this is horse out of the barn, horse still in the barn discussion.
Are you good with the four?
Yeah.
Not yet.
Okay, we're not all there.
You've got to do a little more explaining for Representative Cascade.
Again, so the idea, my last statement, right, so the idea being that this is horse still in the barn before you've let it out versus horse out of the barn.
Now you're closing the barn doors after the fact with a parent making a request for clarification on why data is being released that they may not know is being released.
It gives some clarity.
It gives the district the chance of realizing they might have made a mistake and they're not going to release this data now because they've either got an uprising within the community saying, I don't want my kids data released for this purpose.
Again, the idea being is that if you do it after the release, the parents really have no recourse other than protecting the parents of next year, but if they do it again.
But if you do it before the information is released, it gives parents and community a chance to respond before the data is cut, let loose.
Because once, as you know, once you put something out there, you can't get it back.
So let me try to give a few thoughts to that, Senator.
So ours is saying within 14 school days.
So it could be actually seven days or six days within that time frame.
You're saying that before that release, 14 days prior to the release of the data, that that has to be notified.
So from my perspective right now, I agree with the Senate version that, you know, it could be a very short time that the parent has this information to deal with it the way we have it written.
So any concerns within 14 does not necessarily say before yeah the release it could also mean 14 days after the release yeah it doesn't specifically say so our intent was to say it's before you release the data at least 14 days to give time for the community to respond are you how's everybody with that one right now well i have some questions oh Oh, yeah.
I need something.
Why don't you use your red button, please, Corrie.
Yeah.
I have some questions.
Oh, yeah.
I need something.
Why don't you use your red button, please, Corrine?
Yeah.
Sorry, I don't have an issue with either the House version or the Senate version in terms of the time frame.
What I'm struggling with is the language added to the law, and this is where I'm coming from.
In reading 189.68 and 189.67 on student privacy, I can't help but put my practitioner hat on and have been the result of many, many unfunded mandates in legislature that is required to be enacted in a school district or school.
And student records and student privacy is highly regarded.
I don't care if it's first party, second party, third party, fourth party.
And so I struggle with adding this language because it's already included in the process.
And I really need to know what is the real reason for this?
Am I missing something?
Because I've been on the end, receiving end of many mandates, particularly in 2018 when the data security and governance plans were initiated.
Those required an enormous amount of time and are very detailed by their rights, as they should be.
And I'm just questioning why, what purpose, what does this language serve that is not already served by the current legislation and then in effect a school district is required to develop policy.
And then by golly, you better follow those policies, and you better not release information unless there has been annual parent notification or written consent for individual process.
So I'm trying to wrap my head with, why do we have to add other language that is already covered?
I'm not understanding that part of it.
So somebody needs to help me with that.
Would we like to have the attorney from DOE?
Sure.
That's fine.
Okay, Diane.
We'll elevate you from a full colonel to a one-star general.
Okay, Attorney Fenton, you hear us asking about this issue right here between the two.
Do you have any thoughts on behalf of the department, whether this is needed or not needed?
Good morning.
For the record, Diana Fenton of The department, so we have worked with Representative Cordelli on this bill, and I'm not, the department really doesn't take a position on this.
So I would really kind of defer to this legislative body.
And we have appreciated the ability to speak with Representative Cordelli about our concerns.
And I know that he took those to the Senate and address them with that legislative body to the best of his ability.
I think the department's position is simply neutral, and the concern that we raised with the representative was simply possible unforeseen collateral consequences.
And again, we appreciate his ability to take those to the Senate.
Thank you.
Any questions for the attorney?
Thank you very much.
So the ball's back in our court.
Representative Cordelli, do you have any comments?
Yes.
Just as indicated in one, some of the release of this information under certain conditions is allowed under FERPA.
And so this was an attempt to comply with FERPA, but also to let parents know that information was being released.
That was the intent.
and in terms of the actual issue at hand, in terms of the Senate version and the House version, I have no problem with the Senate version.
Okay, any further?
Yes, Senator.
The whole bill deals with the transferring of student data.
And all we are asking is that the student let the parents know that the data is being transferred.
And all we're asking that be done before a certain date, like 14 days before you send it out.
So if the parents feel there's a need for clarification or anything else, that they have an opportunity to do so before the information goes out.
How does that work when we're working with the College Board and the SAT, and we're allowing the SAT to direct the College Board to directly mail this information to the address of the individual parents, and that's information they have to garner from the DOE.
Does that have to occur each time we do this with these students or not?
Representative Crudeli?
We assume that you have a written consent to transfer the information to the third party.
Again, I just say.
Giving the state of technology now being a technologist, this is not a heavy lift, right?
This is not.
This is a form letter with a mail merge, right?
This is not a heavy lift for a school district.
And again, I think in the effort of keeping a parent informed of where their child's information is going, having that this notification is important.
Further discussion?
Okay, what we're going to do is we're going to just take a short caucus here and be back in.
I have to be going it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, take 10, but I think it's a 1030.
So I want you back.
No, I have three bills in a row.
10, 1030.
Thank you.
In looking at, we're looking at the Senate version, and we're looking at, if you have the side-by-side, we're looking at section two there where it says, if student personally identifiable data is released to a third party, parents of students shall be informed.
we would strike 14 school days in a timely manner before the release date to whom the data is released, what information is released or to be released, and the education purpose for which the information will be used.
So we see some tenses in the verb of being, and is incorrect.
And so we say in a timely manner, that means they're gonna have to do it, and if they don't, then they're gonna get slapped pretty hard by the commissioner that's a timely matter is very subjective yeah you know what it's timely to me may not be to somebody else and i think that's the risk that we're trying to avoid so rick can you read what your changes again what you're looking for?
On part two there, if student personally identifiable data is released to a third party, parents of the student shall be informed in a timely manner before the release date to whom the data is released, not was released.
what information uh uh!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
So I guess, again, to Senator Ward's point, the problem with a timely manner is so subjective to based on who's answering.
I guess it's a day before timely.
It's before I did it.
I sent it out.
Is that a reasonable number?
Is 30 days a reasonable number for somebody else?
It's one of the reasons why we put it.
You know, again, I think think only thing we did was change from the house version to us is we just you know inserted before instead of within the most important part to us is that the parent be notified right and uh we're we want to see if this would work uh if in fact the if if it's not, this needs to be reported to the DOE, to the commissioner, and somebody needs, quote, their hands slapped.
So we'd like to try to do this if we could make the changes initially here.
And if this doesn't work, then to go to the next step.
I think our point was we just wanted to create a minimum window of time before the release of the data that parents get notified right rather than have it be subjective so it's a definitive it doesn't matter if they do it 30 days before as long as they're within a window of time that gives parents the opportunity to say something if they want to say something so I'm not sure that in your question again if I released the data one day before if I give a notice send a notice home with my child one day before the release of the data there's no time for a parent to respond would some um informed uh at least x number of days prior to the release acceptable, at least seven school days prior, something like that.
So you just want to change it.
So again, on the line under the Senate version, besides the is and the was, just change it to 14 to seven days and form seven days prior.
At least seven days so that you have that minimum that you're looking for.
So it's OK with that.
I'm OK with that.
Are we OK with that?
Thank you.
So I think we're at the point then where we're at the point where we're going to have to move forward here.
With language so.
We're going to have to go ahead then and we're going to just caucus briefly for 30 seconds here.
We're going to have to go ahead then and.
We're going to just caucus briefly for 30 seconds here.
We have the thing over there.
It's on the clock.
Yeah, I know it.
So we'll be back and just.
When the red hand gets up in the 12th.
6.
in the 12th you Thank you.
The House is willing to accede to the Senate version.
Would the amendment to change the was is to is?
So there'd be two changes.
And from the House side, we'll take a vote.
Reps and Noble.
Yes, represent yes, represent lag.
Yes, yes, yes.
She's gonna be OK so so that concludes what we are.
We'll get the was is changed to is now we're all running over to state house 100.
Yes, it was a meeting.
Yes, I know it.
OK, off we go.
Before.
Right OK, gotta run.
right okay Thank you.
Thank you.
We're going to have a conference committee on House Bill 1278.
House Bill 1278 is a therapeutic cannabis bill so that we can get beyond having to approve indication by indication for expanding the ability of providers to write certifications for therapeutic cannabis.
This program is one that is now moving towards a more mature stage than when it was initially created.
And as we potentially move to Schedule 3 classification, that will change from the current status with Schedule 1, and it should be treated more like other things that providers can provide.
It also has three of the sections from what I like to call the smorgasbord of Feed Our Kids.
There were a lot of different provisions that the Senate initially put forward.
There are only two that had been supported by the House.
With that, there's an additional third section that was added by the Senate when this was amended.
The Senate Bill 499, which is the Feed Our Kids, is also alive.
It has another part, which is a provision to allow towns to get some funding in an emergency right away and not have to wait for the federal government.
That one is still in process and still in play.
It looks quite optimistic.
But my biggest question now would be, regardless of what happens with 499, is the Senate 100% committed to keeping the language in paragraph 3 of 1278?
That is the one that adds into the school's food and nutrition programs.
One that quite frankly takes quite a bit of research to understand the implications and was not accepted in either of the amendments that came out of House Finance.
Section 3 of the bill, it's on page 1, lines 10 through 21.
So that is what's different different between 499 as attached to this bill and 499 as passed by the house can we have a one minute break yes so we'll be in recess for one minute Thank you.
Thank you.
And we are back for House Bill 1278.
Do you want any?
Sure.
I think our position at this point is that, you know, it's all part of the conversation, particularly with 499 and the ongoing conversations with disaster relief.
So I think at this point, the Senate would be most comfortable just recessing this bill and coming back tomorrow after the committee of conference on 499.
And then it will be all part of that conversation.
I think that's sort of where we're at.
Okay, thank you.
I'm just trying to understand what conversation we'll be having if the Senate, if we end up passing 499 with both sections, which is what I believe, with both sections in some form, which is what I believe would need to happen for 499 to pass.
If that passes, would the Senate be willing to recede from their amendment and accede to the House position on this bill?
So I haven't had a chance to go to any of the 499 committees of conference because I've had a couple of things scheduled.
So my understanding is that the disaster relief changes the law that we just passed in 2022.
That being said, I think what we saw with the flooding in the seacoast this year and the slow response of getting a FEMA declaration, that there some merit to what is being proposed.
The question is the amount.
And I think that that's under discussion.
So just like that's under discussion, you know, free and reduced lunch should be under discussion.
Hopefully we can roll this all together where everybody leaves happy.
Nobody gets everything, but we have a compromise that we can pass both of these.
Okay?
Thank you.
So I'm not saying yes and I'm not saying no.
So you're saying that, assuming that Senate Bill 499 is passed, perhaps with the $50,000 amount that helps the Seacoast, helps the North Country, helps our communities when, because the federal government's too slow to act.
Assuming that that passes, you still will be looking to have all three items from the school lunch.
Oh, your microphone's off.
It all gets wrapped in to the same discussion, okay, of what a good compromise looks like.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
I also appreciate that my job here isn't necessarily to have my position, but to represent the position of the House, and the position of the House is those two items.
Well, and remember, the Senate killed the disaster relief bill because we had just passed something a couple of years ago.
Thank you.
I recognize that.
Unfortunately, it seems that what we passed a few years ago still needs some more change.
And I also recognize how busy we've all been this year.
We all put in too many bills.
I know I'm guilty of that.
And I know that that led to a lot of the challenges we're dealing with right now.
I guess we'll recess until 3 o'clock tomorrow, but we'll recess until 3 o'clock tomorrow.
Thank you.
Sorry, can you be there at 3 o'clock tomorrow?
I apologize.
Sorry, Senator Whitley had suggested that as a time.
I forgot to check it with the rest of you.
I know Senator Bradley and Senator Abarth are also very busy.
Right now, yes.
Okay.
If I can't be here, Okay.
okay okay if you'll make it work we'll recess this until three o'clock tomorrow thank you Thank you.
Thank you.